hello welcome to gamestop plays
doubleheader i'm playing fifa 60 we also
played Pro Evolution Soccer 2016 it's
all happening today in the world of
football Eric Taylor's here which means
we have to playing football games and
buy generic yeah again good to see you
cm FIFA course we give it a nine out of
ten today on gamespot com oh oh and this
airs well when this airs we are breaking
embargo right now but hopefully this is
mayra distant life and and we showed off
program in an earlier video while
depending on which way you watch these
so now I'm going to show up FIFA the
first things a bit fifa is modes modes
most modes modes bones modes the amount
of different ways to play this game with
the stages with ridiculous and ultimate
teens back and there is a new foot draft
mode which is like a compartmentalised
version of that which is pretty good
smaller less sort of all involving have
you tried it yet i tried it on an event
i try to like gamescom it was pretty
good how long does it take to get from
picking into the game into the game not
that long but it's also like maybe five
minutes it's also fun it's a much more
fun process you get higher degree level
players as well and career mode all the
different tournaments you could ever
want and women's soccer makes a first
appearance not a lot of teens it's not a
lot of teams is 10 international teams
and so they have a sort of a fake world
cup there because they can't have them
all in nope it's 12 no clubs whatsoever
only international team and so you can
you can make your your go-to tournament
there also available in friendlies
online of course has all its crazy stuff
pro clubs seasons coop seasons all my
friend these here's a button for twitch
for some reason and you can play the
interactive world cup I don't even know
what that is matchday live has the usual
array of random goal articles which you
can read or this one which is probably
some sort of image gallery that doesn't
work in FIFA but it's still there for
some reason and all the crazy settings
ever well my favorite menu and FIFA is
the one up in the top rice this thing
which no one ever uses scott knows every
nice thing hey look I'm gonna spend
coins on on goal celebrations I don't
buy like three of them gonna buy the
Prancing bird goal celebration dawn fifa
is a big game and that's probably one of
the big focuses of our review as well as
the fact that there's a lot of ways to
play fifa and there's a lot of you know
it's been an iterative game and they've
changed it over the years
it's largely the same game and they
change gameplay tweaks and whatnot but
the one thing they have done is they've
actually had a lot of they added in two
modes and it generally not taken away
too many and what were the big changes
that they made this year in terms of
like mechanic will get into once we get
into the game we're gonna I'm gonna do
half of I'm gonna be half one half
against AI and then we'll get you in
okay yep so you played as man united in
the other one so let's I'm gonna go with
our smoke exam I time how about how
about I will can I pick you can pick you
come back I need you any one you want
you could pick up unique you can't pick
women's team if you're sadly forever
right so if I can go to women's here but
if I do that then I'm locked into women
they want a cheap ICS pawn right there
so I'm gonna go see if you want ours I'm
gonna go to Ghana Johnson I will go with
you our arch-nemesis Chelsea yo Rock
eyes it's hoping you'd say Spurs no but
uh yeah I guess but I'm gonna I'm gonna
really terrorize you at Diego Costa I
really prefer I really appreciate it
let's put it on and I'll do it on
world-class just so it's a little ish
I'm sorry usually play so it's gonna be
a little bit harder and added you know
it's gonna be a bit of chit-chatting
happening i'm still not a fan of these
modes menus they did in the last game
bubble will do oh you don't like this
interface I actually like it I don't
remember what it was like before that's
the thing you never remember what was
like for it's like what do the xbox
dashboard looked like before it's like I
don't remember and they got bunch more
skill games in here as well this is an
old favorite I had the board Santa Claus
orla taking a oh look at us off the bar
and in okay of course because this is
next-gen by the time you've done any of
this the game is ready to load in so
whatever so we'll skip to it alright so
mechanically one of the things last year
do was a massive problem was basically
the fastest teams won it was a massive
amount of like counter-attack running
sprinting down the wings getting balls
in and the fences weren't really armed
well enough to cope with that and so it
sort of made especially online stuff
like a massive counter-attack and if you
could get that one through ball and you
basically had it so what they've done is
the the the general play
the battles happen a lot more in the
middle of the park now which is an
absolute must because last year's game
had that was a massive issue so what I
found I hopefully will see what we're
doing or playing on world class so
hopefully it should be it should be
apparent pretty early on is that getting
the ball into the attacking almost
almost like pro web 2016 actually is a
lot more challenging yeah so you've a
lot more it's a lot more work happening
here in the muleta park and so are you
this is a [ __ ] I was not very world
class of me cuz its back and they've
also added a new button which I
hopefully use if he doesn't score on
with God what's coming button it's a
drilled pass it's basically like a like
a little cross now watch days I'll try
and do it gets lb meets this one I just
forget which one is gotcha there that's
it right so it's kind of like a you
point at the part of the pitch where you
want to put the ball and you'd run it
and it gets in there see yeah yeah so
don't you will if you have to get it
between two defenders yes it's really
good for splitting it I what I like
about it is because it has that manual
element to it it's not going to be it's
not gonna be like the the true bold the
triangle ship which is like Oh Howard
yeah and just everyone can use I got
feel like this this one is going to be
more like if you're if you're good at
using it it'll be really useful if
you're bad at using it you're gonna
snooker yourself a lot a bit like the
trip will be low wall cross yeah except
when you when you mess up that the trip
will be it kind of its you know we just
messed up a shot whereas in this one if
you miss up one of these drill balls all
of your players haven't reacted to the
past like they're doing FIFA you know
when you pass the ball in FIFA the
players react almost instantly like wach
wach murders occur so pull away or that
was murders occur apologies I was
Gabrielle gonna get his ass sent off and
like the players react or is it not when
it's almost like you've taken them by
surprise which is kind of cool yeah so
like the play in the middle of the park
is a little bit more difficult it's not
as snappy and easiest pro evolution as
well so basically it kind of creates a
difficult experience it creates a more
challenging game one thing one thing you
talked about in
a pro evil video was how the defenders
close you down really quickly yes and
right off the bat I noticed that yeah
there's a stark contrast between this
and probably though the defenders and
fee fault tend to sort of lay off and
play zone a bit more yeah especially in
the midfield like it's it's not a bad
running guy and that shows you the big
difference between anything pro having
people which is the probe has played in
a much faster pace yeah and it's all
about like trying to break in there and
then get the shot away there they just
did the computer just played that low
ball yea high pass come on you know hard
it is generally to talk and play fifa
yeah I'm law class oh [ __ ] when your own
world class we've just come from playing
a bunch of pro f 0 got down at Pedro
that's pain yes BS that's dad oh well
when we started half we'll just we'll
consider yeah ok so matter what the
score so let me skip it it's the one
good thing about FIFA is that it won't
default to a replay when I score can see
to go as long as I don't get one my
players sent off i'll be i'll be happy
and obviously last year they added in
the ultra attack and all-out attack and
of course the park the bus on the other
side and so that all returns a tactic
used often by marine by mr. Murray oh
yeah you could say cleaned it all right
here we go I'm gonna be super cynical
bold in the wing what a ball oh good
great ball thanks neatly feel better I'm
losing my ass what class do cake
chocolate it is there's also loads of
fun way more fun you're not getting
challenged in FIFA look at this jerk
again challenge antifa there's no point
like you can sit down and play these
games and knock out like well wings in a
row if you just see that was it that was
the little drill ball ya ready that's a
good through ball yeah it's it's like a
yeah but you have to like place it
yourself so it's [ __ ] oh oh I don't the
angle that was made it look like those
going yeah I thought that was just a lot
of slaughter so you mentioned that and
they really emphasize sort of making a
ball play go through the middle more and
when you're using things like real
Madrid or Barcelona you can't just fly
down the wings
and you know destroy teams that way yeah
did you find that not only in the AI but
when you play another person have you
had the opportunity plan on else and
find out like if the defenders act the
same way and I still do it with that
yeah well because i like the pre-release
nature of this i haven't been playing
online yet so that's been a bit of a
pain in the ass and I just wonder how
that'll affect you know online play cuz
of course when you get into the upper
leagues of dew line play everyone always
chooses Madrid Madrid or Barcelona dude
I share cast as a fifa tourney with a
couple years ago and literally i think
two teams didn't pick real madrid one of
them was like when I was Chelsea and
they got into the semi-final and we get
a bill Munich it was my music yeah yeah
but like it was just Ramage after I
Madrid about gibberish manager I think
the same thing will probably happen
because like you know the online fifa
world is a competitive world so like
people always going to propagate to
those two sure yeah but i'm not i'm not
you know i'm i'm sure people will find a
way to make the best teams work but i
think it'll go on Oh a nice ball in this
box oh I always what I don't think it's
going to be that I always found that
Munich work best for me but I'm more of
a possession player I don't think you'd
want to choose Madrid if your possession
player you want to play down the wings
and just go yeah I always pick for your
teams always pick arseling you've a or
something arsenal why what happened we
got injured Ramsey alright we bring on
typical Ramsey on Giroux and defense we
stick the oxygen on whatever he's yeah
we'll them do their to get back in the
game and one thing as well hopefully
there's a gameplay clip off on gamespot
add the one talk about new additions in
FIFA the magics f referee spray is in
this game really here they did yeah so
if I maybe let's do a free later on if
there's a free knee of the box and he
will straight up to do the magic spray
on the page and does it disappear it
does this very time like you run over it
as you play together that's cool that it
disappears there you go there you go we
go we got a female f football for once
and also magic spray India it's like
when they did the world cup 1 and
vuvuzelas room like
maybe I don't want this wait could you
turn those off in the world cup one and
they had their own villas yeah they had
their own audio [ __ ] God thank you they
weren't anywhere near as loud as they
were in real life though because that
the guess because they didn't know they
assume there's gonna be vuvuzelas we
didn't know how they're doing at me all
right so one mill dam patter check
against his old team that's let's get
you in the mixer so we can sounds like
you but I think I got the right controls
let's see I gotta get out settings yours
I would have to do it here where is it
like sides look at this [ __ ] look at
these absolute never got used to these
go to settings the songs uh flex yes of
course we're on pro evolution controls
yes of course such as our heritage this
is the first first time I played this so
oh is it yeah i'm sorry i love
informations right uh I didn't come
vidya here so um since last year's game
Oh in the trainer's I leave it on livin
on leave it on what is that the trainer
is basically it gives you contextual I
think things and also no question yes
but also learns how good you are so with
the start it's gonna be saying pass the
ball take a shot but after like pretty
soon like after like a bit of a game
it'll basically start telling you God
there's too much tag stop in here i'm
gonna turn mine off yeah okay I do you a
got it all right again let's leave the
one of the month and after a while it
does figure out that you're able to do
like a bunch of thing so you know that
this in a bunt this in a few of the
games it's in NHL as well and it's
really good at distracting you from what
we're me like response this would be a
fun video to make leave that on all game
maybe not good for two player maybe it's
a little bit better suited for uh for AI
no way no way you start bitching a day
late oh god I will call that one ought
not to elbow 10 I wonder if it gives you
contextual I am
like what celebration you should pull
off at this time do the dead fish I got
a little lucky down the header oh come
on skip it oh sorry signs forgot how
dare you all right we'll say it's it's
one nail for you but it's 2-nil for me
so I'm better I better turn it on oh
yeah that's right I've worked out pretty
well oh ouch yeah but so otherwise like
this the first thing we're playing is it
feels like last year's people right yeah
no good job it's minor tweaks right so
it's there it's there it's there profits
they're like cross the bear and at all
you've got to be kidding me thank God my
goodness yeah it's the key to their
success and their cross the Barrett of
like these games are pretty solid so the
stuff they add like thankfully they've
you know fixed what was a sort of a
general problem with the gameplay last
year oh I'm gonna fix you in a second
there's no one else up here Sanchez's on
his own oh you said put it in a no god
damn it Alexis run past everyone this is
gonna be real tense last 30 minutes of
this game just throwing them all in and
throwing them all in that's it come on
this is the arslan we should have Hodge
also it hot it helps that we only need
two players non-consent all for this leg
yeah you suck drills that little drill
ball it's right it's what's the drug why
again so you can if you hit or be it'll
or l-1 if you're playing on ps4 and all
hit it wherever you're pointing
basically look at this ticket acha
no wonder what is he doing I have no
idea what is happening come on get off
the pitch I need to stop doing this
counter-attack stuff is not working
don't last you say oh no give me a
second shot yeah that's it put me back
in coach this is like becoming their the
scrappy ridiculous 1v1 thief if we're
just lucky you need to score as quickly
as possible very open play Oh No so
that's the difference in pro I've like a
fight pass that ball back I would have
gone straight to his feet like there are
a lot more punishing and FIFA when it
comes to that I wish I think you and I
like as we played this enough words more
challenging that way yeah like probe is
sort of challenging in different types
of ways and I think that's kind of the
way about these games is that like I
said the other other game swap lies its
to differences in inches rather than
miles so like you the things that the
things that irritate you about one game
are very very slight differences that
they have between the two largely so
it's all down to preference you know
it's all dental what you want oh la
banda late card yeah don't run after him
leave me alone leave something Santa
Claus alone what's antique cars all is a
theme song asanti goes on
you know classic oh my check statement
keep it in mind my favorite one was in
Abu Dhabi played for us and we'd all
sing diaby diaby diaby diaby he knocked
out John Terry diaby all right machine I
did but you know I got to give Arsenal
credit does it does it kind of fun we're
not--we're know like this better teams
better teams in London like Renault West
time or like Chris lipolysis are getting
some rice live inside London Crystal
Palace got some really good fans now but
they're not gonna win this game like
Arsenal oh you scum look at you all
right I wanna hit pass hey what's going
on over there until I was hugging each
other on the ground I think I I went in
really late on him I can't believe
haven't called I oh he's injured he's
injured here we go outside know what you
do we're gonna do Oh audacious what are
you doing don't you dare beat me like
this on an Internet video hey dick oh my
god this is humiliating oh no send them
all off they're all out attack they can
have to keep up oh my god oh you gotta
be kidding me Oh congratulations Eric
Taylor yeah we won't ruin the other one
if anyone hasn't watched the pro our
video if you haven't watched the prior
video and you've just watch this v 460
video go watch it and if you watch the
other prior video and you've come watch
this congratulations cuz to reboot games
connectors here both 9 out of 10 on
gamespot and book difference and let's
sort of good in their own unique way
Eric before we go if you had to pick
which one right now coming as somebody
who plays on probe controls but has been
playing for you for the past couple
years which one would you pick you have
to pick one fifa and i'm just i said in
the other
when we were playing it's mainly because
of friends all my friends are on FIFA
that's where I get the most enjoyment if
all my friends were on pro evo I might
switch but even still I'm just more used
to the subtleties of FIFA yeah and you
play a lot online right so yeah a lot
online a lot on the league's the tiered
leaves where you move your way up so but
then also friendlies with friends
talking trash and all that yeah um so I
don't know it maybe in a year or two
might go back but for now fifa for me I
think imma fight I I think I think the
new PES is really good I think there are
some AI foibles that I kind of don't
necessarily like the licenses because I
place so much premier league stuff and
exhibition games with like Arsenal
particularly like that works me like
United's in PES but no one else's yeah
in the Premier League or the English
league or whatever it's called so like
for me again based on the like checklist
of things that i like doing if i had to
pick one a pic fifa but like all I
playbook games a rear and I think this
year's pass is really good and if you
are you know look at about picking which
footy game to get this year then you
should definitely check out the demo is
at least yeah that's pretty much why do
you live exactly and thanks for watching
hopefully this is bear proved to be
useful in that purchasing decision as
well so thank you so much for hanging
out with our gamespot plays football
special today and for everything else
about pro evolution soccer and fifa stay
tuned to gamespot com
you
you